dr. Baden thank you for being back with
us I've known you a long time yes you
know my background now in martial arts I
have I looked at this video again and
again I saw that neck I saw that that
that push into the pavement I knew
immediately that is the most vulnerable
part of the human anatomy unless you
care to correct that statement you did
the autopsy tell us what you saw and
compared it also to what you saw in the
video yes you and I agree very much that
the neck is has a great deal of nerves
blood vessels arteries veins and
windpipe and pressure in that area
whether it's the front or the side or
the back can impair blood flow to the
brain bring up the oxygen brain that can
be impaired of breathing through the
windpipe now in addition to that and
what could die just from compression of
the neck sufficiently there's was
compression that you can see the videos
of the back pregnant pressure on the
back prevents the diaphragms from moving
up and down which is necessary to inhale
and exhale and that's the kind of
pressure that caused Eric garner and now
George Floyd to sack can't breathe but
the police are the big misconception in
the Shorin among police that if a person
can talk and say I can't breathe that
means he's breathing now I'm talking to
you now for awhile without breathing I
keep talking you don't need to be
breathing in order to say I can't
breathe who are warm in this instead
when Floyd reaches out because for his
mother mama mama who died three years
ago
and still nobody lessened up their
pressure on him I think the finding was
at the autopsy that he did not have any
other reason to cause death he
heart lungs and other things were not
sufficiently impaired that would have
caused death and the video of the
pressure on the neck and on the back is
what establishes that he couldn't
breathe and goes along with his
statements that he couldn't breathing
he's telling the truth and he died
because he didn't get enough oxygen his
brain just like our Eric Gardner
remembered Eric Gardner Barnard from the
time the police touched him Sean to the
time that they got off him and realized
he was in that he was lifeless was about
48 seconds if there's no blood going to
the brain and if he can't move his
diaphragms one can die very quickly and
the videos Lloyd became lifeless in less
than four minutes he was moving around
and he was able to breathe and then
stopped breathing and I think that the
pressure should have been let off him
but he died of compression because he
couldn't breathe and because his brain
wasn't getting enough oxygen dr. Baden
the original preliminary report and a
medical examiner now I'd now believe is
on the same page with you I didn't like
it because it it said there was this it
was not that buy fix fix iation
this is what I know from my martial arts
training if I put you in a with what's
called a rear naked choke where you have
both literally carotid arteries and I
have access or the trach in the
different hold but I put you in a rear
naked choke you're gonna drop to your
knees in 15 seconds you said at the
press conference today that you believed
he was dead five minutes into this if
you watch to the end of the video it
will break anybody's heart you could see
they had to separately hold his head and
neck up to get him on the gurney you he
was dead for at least a couple of
minutes right there at the scene they
they did not they they said he died at
the hospital that's not true I've know
was the original preliminary report yeah
the they tried to do CPR with them going
in the ambulance and they couldn't get a
pulse he had a cardiac arrest and they
tried to shock him and the shock didn't
work he was dead as he said before they
put him into this stretcher the the
situation this country should is is that
the death met the death time on the
certificate is not when you died but
when the a doctor pronounces you dead if
we have a decomposed body coming out
with a Hudson River tomorrow it'll hat
tomorrow it'll have tomorrow's data's at
the time of death because that he's
pronounced even though he may have been
dead for four months before that so the
death certificate is awkward and it has
the pronounced time of death not the
actual time of death and I agree with
you he's dead long before he get many
minutes before he gets to the hospital
from a medical perspective and you know
what a rear naked choke is if I put you
in a rear naked choke am i wrong and
telling this audience that in 15 seconds
if I have you and I have both carotid
and I'm putting heavy pressure on it
that an average person will drop in 15
seconds less than that in less than 10
seconds and that's the kind of choke
that a well-trained police officer can
do should never use never can do in the
old days they use it and was used
properly a personal collapse in about
ten seconds and have planned a time to
put the handcuffs on however a lot of
police had that choke on too long and it
can cause death and it is safer never
compress the neck never also not get on
the back and press on the back because
that can cause death from lack of
breathing and it's interesting that
about in 2010 there was a similar death
named Smith David Smith who died under
similar circumstances couldn't breathe
that
his back and the Minneapolis Police
Department use it as a as a way of
training police officers in not to put a
chokehold on and not to get on the back
of a person and release the pursuit as
they get them under control
and this has been used as a teaching
kind of case from ten years ago yet
whatever happened they did the wrong
thing in this case yeah and you know dr.
Baden if you have targeted strike two
I've been trying to tell the artifact of
my hand and I hit my target and I hit it
hard enough
a person's ROPS to their knees
immediately one strike and if they try
to stand up they'll probably fall down
again is that also accurate yeah yes
shorten your that's interesting I've
gotten a number of emails from people
who do martial arts to say just what
you're saying is that when they saw the
way he was that the knee was on the neck
and that kind of pressure can cause
rapid loss of consciousness and rapid
injury to the person just from a number
of martial arts people will you please
tell I know now you were hired by the
family please send are many many prayers
[Music]
something good will come out of this how
about we never do this again ever
all right thank you dr. Bodnar